I'm Charlton Heston I'm very pleased to
join with you tonight in honoring a man
whose name is legendary in the world of
entertainment dr. Jules Stein
he founded the Music Corporation of
America and served as its president or
chairman for 47 years in its present
position of eminence in the field of
entertainment is a tribute to his
leadership but we honor dr. Stein
tonight not as a brilliant executive but
as a dedicated human being a few miles
from here stands his most distinguished
achievement the renowned Jules Stein eye
Institute of UCLA it's one of 50 medical
institutions across the country engaged
in fighting blinding diseases with
support from research to prevent
blindness the nation's leading
organization in I research of which dr.
Stein is co-founder and principal
benefactor his work in this field has
been repeatedly honored he was joined
such recipients as Sir Winston Churchill
and Helen Keller in receiving the
Humanitarian Award a variety clubs
international he was recently presented
with a prestigious Albert Lasker public
service award tonight
it's the privilege of this Academy to
present to him the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award for his extraordinary
achievements in the saving of sight and
the enrichment of human life dr. Stein
honors us by accepting
Thank You jargon and thank the women men
of the Academy I'm a highly honored and
indeed grateful I'm also proud to have
made a meaningful contribution in the
field of ophthalmology it is a rewarding
experience to stand here tonight knowing
that among the millions of viewers
watching this show there are thousands
upon thousands who could not be seeing
it and enjoying it were it not primarily
for the work of our national
organization research to prevent
blindness I&C
nor would they have been able to see the
performers and the motion pictures you
are honoring here tonight in honoring me
you honor all those dedicated to the
saving of sight and the prevention of
blindness
you